oh
[Musique]
sur un tango boxing unis ils se portent
guère qu'une offre du show kaehlin et
borelli
[Musique]
le chef
ça me
[Musique]
jeanne est une danse très difficile
paraît-il sa sublime un gâteau proulx et
le sucre et benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur une longue bada le livre officiel
épisode joey starr gilles verdez et sa
partenaire
ludivine rhétorique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pas tous français
sur un roc le séduisant mais salle jean
michel maire et sa partenaire qui a une
entorse au gros orteil
mais qui est quand même pas très triste
[Applaudissements]
le prince de la télévision est le roi du
paf en général cyril hanouna et son
partenaire qui ne pourra jamais dire la
même chose
mathieu de lambeaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]